Hello, how are you? Cristian
Cásseres greets you with his previous news report on
Kirchner in Spanish. The Department of
Labor reported that US companies
added 266,000
jobs in April. This was a
tremendous surprise, since it was expected to
exceed one million.  As
states prepare to reopen after
being given the green light to allow more
business capacity in this regard,
average unemployment during
this time period remains the
same at 6.1 percent,
and Pachi Rivero is actually
hosting a job fair.  work on
friday and saturday you must attend the nobody
with forest located near oakley and
todd haynes this event will be from 10 in the
morning to 2 in the afternoon it is recommended to
fill out the application before showing up
at the place for this you must enter the
page  that rivers dotcom
applicants must be 18 years of age
orwell employment of southern nevada will
also be hosting a job fair
on fri  ernes located inside the
boulevard shopping center there will be several
leaders from different companies such as
web assemblies the
clark county school district among others
remember to take several copies of your
resume and be ready for an
interview right there and finally
we move on to the weather forecast today
friday we will reach the  90 degrees and
also, well, it will continue at that level
for the rest of the weekend.
The winds are expected to return on
Saturday, but for Sunday,
Mother's Day, a sunny and very pleasant day is expected,
after which we will have a small
drop in temperatures.  but they
will go up again as usual for
this time of year I am cristian cásseres
with his brief disney news in
Spanish good day
[Music]